the reason I took the jellyfish UFO
seriously is cuz I have direct firsthand
knowledge of a video of a jellyfish UFO
coming in down between the nuclear silos
and then popping up and shooting off at
45° with instantaneous movement are
there more UFO sightings around big
bodies of water if you are going between
Star systems and planets right you have
to worry about what like heat and
pressure atmosphere right what is going
to be the same anywhere in the Galaxy if
you have liquid water it has has to be
within a very narrow temperature and
there's going to be a very narrow amount
of pressure depending on the depth of
that water so that could be why water
has always played a role in lakes and
oceans and they are absolutely reported
coming in and out of the water I
released radar thermal infrared and deck
footage from 2019 with 10 warships being
swarmed simultaneously by over 100 UFOs
it was confirmed by the Pentagon so man
look it's happening